you uh like i mentioned with with spacex
you give a lot of people hope and a lot
of people look up to you millions of
people look up to you uh if we think
about young people
in high school maybe in college
what advice would you give to them about
if they want to try to do something big
in this world they want to really have a
big positive impact what advice would
you give them about their career maybe
about life in general
try to be useful
um
you do things that are useful to your
fellow human beings to the world
it's very hard to be useful
um
very hard
um you know are you contributing more
than you
consume you know like uh
like
can you
try to have a positive net contribution
to society um
i think that's the thing to aim for you
know not not to try to be sort of a
leader for
just for the sake of being a leader or
whatever um
a lot of time people who
a lot of times the people you want as
leaders are other people who don't want
to be leaders
so
um
if you live a useful life
that is a good life
a life worth
having lived
um
you know and i'd like i said i would
i would encourage people to
use the mental tools of physics and
apply them broadly in life
there are the best tools when you think
about education and self-education what
do you recommend
so there's the university there's
uh self-study
there is a hands-on sort of finding a
company or a place or a set of people
that do the thing you're passionate
about and joining them as early as
possible
um
there's uh taking a road trip across
europe for a few years and writing some
poetry which uh which which trajectory
do you suggest
for in terms of learning about
how you can become useful as you
mentioned how you can have the most
positive impact
what i encourage people to read a lot of
books
just re like
basically try to ingest as much
information as you can
uh
and try to also just develop a good
general knowledge
so
you so you at least have like
a rough lay of the land of the the
knowledge landscape
like try to learn a little bit about a
lot of things
because you might not know what you're
really interested how would you know
what you're really interested in if you
at least aren't like doing it
peripheral exploration or broadly of
of
the knowledge landscape
um
and
you talk to people from different walks
of life and different uh
industries and professions and skills
and like what
occupations like just try you know
learn as much as possible
man search for meaning
isn't the whole thing a search for
meaning
is
yeah what's the meaning of life and all
you know
but just generally like i said i would
encourage people to read broadly
um in many different subject areas um
and and and then try to find something
where there's an overlap of your talents
and
and what you're interested in so people
may may be good at something but or they
may have
skill at a particular thing but they
don't like doing it
um
so you want to try to find a thing where
you ha you're
that's a good a good uh combination of
of yours of the things that you're
inherently good at but you also like
doing
um
and um and reading is a super fast
shortcut to to figure out which where
are you you both good at it you like
doing it and it will actually have
positive impact
well you got to learn about things
somehow so re reading
a broad range just really
read it
you know the more important was that kid
i i
read through the encyclopedia
so
that was pretty helpful
um
and uh
also things i didn't even know existed
little lots obviously and it's like as
broad as it gets encyclopedias were
digestible i think
uh you know whatever 40 years ago
um
so
you know we read through the the
condensed version of the encyclopedia
britannica i'd recommend that
um you can always like skip subjects so
you read a few paragraphs and you know
you're not interested just jump to the
next one
so read the encyclopedia or scan
skim through it
um
and um
but you know i put a lot of stock and
certainly have a lot of respect for
someone who puts in an honest day's work
uh to do useful things
and
and just generally to have like not a
zero-sum mindset um
or
like have more of a grow the pie mindset
like the
if you sort of say like
when when we see people like perhaps um
including some very smart people
kind of uh taking an attitude of like
like doing things that seem like morally
questionable
it's often because they have at a base
sort of axiomatic level a zero sum
mindset
um and and they
without realizing it they don't realize
they have a zero-sum mindset or at least
that they don't realize it consciously
um and so if you have zero-sum mindset
then the only way to get ahead is by
taking things from others
if it's like if
if the if the pi is fixed then the only
way to have more pie is to take someone
else's pie
but but this is false like obviously the
pie has grown dramatically over time the
economic pie
so
in reality you can have
so overuse this analogy if you have a
lot of we can have this a lot of pi
yeah
is not fixed um
uh so you really want to make sure you
don't you're not operating um
without realizing it from a zero-sum
mindset
where the only way to get ahead is to
take things from others then that's
going to result in you trying to take
things from others which is not not good
it's much better to work on
uh
adding to the economic pie you know so
uh you know creating
like i said creating more than you
consume uh doing more than you
yeah um
so that's that's a big deal um i think
there's like
you know a fair number of people in
in finance that
uh do have a bit of a zero-sum mindset
i mean it's all walks of life i've seen
that one of the one of the reasons
uh rogan inspires me is he celebrates
all there's a lot
there's not
not creating a constant competition like
there's a scarcity of resources what
happens when you celebrate others and
you promote others
the ideas of others
it uh it actually grows that pie i mean
it the every like the
uh the resource the resources become
less scarce
and that that applies in a lot of kinds
of domains it applies in academia where
a lot of people are very
uh see some funding for academic
research is zero sum and it is not if
you celebrate each other if you make if
you get everybody to be excited about ai
about physics above mathematics i think
it there'd be more and more funding and
i think everybody wins yeah that applies
i think broadly
uh yeah yeah exactly
you